"Just do it!"
"Do it!"
Shia LaBeouf, 2012.
(jazzy music)
♫ Whine about it
♫ Whine about it ♫
- Hey everyone, my name is Matt Bellassai,
and this is "Whine About
It," a weekly video series
where I get drunk at my desk
and complain about stuff.
On this week's episode, reasons mornings
are the absolute worst.
Because morning people
were created by the devil
to spread sin and evil.
And I'll never be awake
enough to deal with that shit.
But first, let's drink.
(upbeat music)
- Ew, that's a strong one.
(groaning)
Ew okay, that's enough.
Alright, first of all mornings
are just a daily reminder
that I have responsibilities
that I have to take care of,
which I spend a lot of time
trying to forget about.
And every time my alarm clock goes off,
it's just like "beep beep you have a job,"
"beep beep you have bills to pay,"
"beep beep you have a drinking problem
"that your mom keeps telling you
"you should seriously consider addressing,
"but you just don't feel like it."
I just don't need that
kind of pressure in my life
before my eyes are even open.
Why can't I agonize over
all my life problems
at like 3 pm instead?
It is cruel and unusual
punishment to expect me
to be awake and presentable to the world
moments after I get out of bed.
I can barely pee in the
toilet, let alone face
the (bleep) world.
Next, the human body just
isn't built for mornings,
or not this one.
You ever see what I look
like in the morning?
My breath smells, my hair is (bleep),
and my eyes look like the
bottom of an empty jar
of grape jelly.
Just raw, like a goopy new born baby.
My body isn't ready to confront the world,
until I've had at least
three cups of coffee,
cereal, a nap, and lunch.
Then you can (bleep) deal
with me, because I'm not
doing shit before that.
Also, getting out of bed
is already struggle enough.
I have enough shit to do
before I even take the covers
off my face.
I gotta check Instagram,
Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram again, that's
all stuff I gotta do
before I even get out of bed.
Before I even open my eyes, I
gotta check all those things.
My bed is like a warm, toasty
oven, and I'm the delicate
flaky pastry inside.
You wouldn't take a
delicate flaky pastry out of
its warm toasty oven, while
he's in there being all warm
and delicious and flaky.
No, you wouldn't, you'd
let him sit in there.
You would let him be.
Why get out of bed, when
you just lay there forever
until you shrivel and die.
Next, morning people are just the worst.
They're just the (bleep) worst.
Congratulations, you got up at six am,
and flailed your sweaty thighs
to an 80's work out DVD,
while I face (bleep) my pillow
for an extra three hours.
Well joke's on you, because
me sleeping is better
than anything you'll do
with your whole (bleep) life
while you're awake.
Okay?
Also, morning people are
always saying how much
(bleep) shit they can
get done before everybody
else wakes up.
"Oh, I can go to the bank."
"Oh, I can mail all my letters."
"I can clean my apartment."
That's what they always say.
You know when I clean my apartment?
Three minutes before anyone comes over.
You know, just in a drunken, naked,
sweaty hurricane.
Clothes are going everywhere,
my ass is hanging out,
not in the (bleep) damn morning,
that's for (bleep) damn sure.
Finally, everything is
just better at night.
Even breakfast is better at night.
You think I wanna eat
breakfast while the sun is out?
When everybody can see
me jamming a whole waffle
into my face, while hot
syrup runs down my chin?
I wanna eat my waffles
in the cover of darkness,
under the moon, like a
hungry waffle jackal.
Just howling in the night.
In conclusion, mornings are full of shit,
and I don't have to (bleep)
deal with it if I don't want to,
so you can go (bleep) right off, mornings.
Alright everybody, thank
you for watching this week.
As always you can find
our videos every week,
on "WineAboutIt.Tober.com,"
and my page which is
Facebook.com/BuzzfeedMatt.
And you can find our videos on YouTube
on Buzzfeed video.
And that's about everything,
that's all of it.
It's about time I go back to bed I think.
♫ Wine about it
♫ Wine about it! ♫
- Ahh.
Boom, set, we're done.
Turn it off!
Did you turn it off?
- [Voiceover] No.
- Okay, I think we're done.
- [Voiceover] You sure?
- I don't know, maybe I'll get funny.
You never know, you never know.